technology is ever evolving
despite the fact that covid has been
calling shots for the last year we have
seen some incredible growth in
technology there has been a massive rise
in tech innovation in the field of
medicine
healthcare
ai and blockchain among others needless
to say these technologies are
transforming our lives today
on that note hey guys welcome to this
video by simply learn
today we will be discussing top
technologies that promise a brighter
future
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
edge computing is a current technology
development that brings data storage and
computation closer to businesses
improving reaction times and reducing
bandwidth usage it is also considered to
be the most recent technological trend
because enterprises are rapidly gaining
access to sophisticated and specialized
resources which is sure to reduce
latency
edge computing raises security to new
heights by addressing local compliance
privacy legislation and data sovereignty
concerns
although many people feel that edge
computing increases the attack surfaces
it really reduces the influence of an
enterprise
other benefits of edge computing include
enhanced speed and reduced costs top
tier companies like dell aws google
cloud platform
hpe and ibm among others are readily
adopting edge computing
human augmentation a technique of
enhancing a person's physical and
cognitive abilities is known as human
augmentation
once implanted in a person it will allow
them to perform activities that were
previously impossible human augmentation
one of the most recent technological
advancements in the post-modern age
would not only improve a person's
physical endurance but also their
ability to think and make better
decisions to put it in another way we
can argue that human augmentation has a
lot of promise for the future of
technology
google samsung electronics
fossil group among others are top market
players
ai
artificial intelligence or ai has proven
to be one of today's most transformative
tech evolutions
however with the current world scenario
artificial intelligence seems more
promising than ever
trends in the ai technologies such as
alter ego
a mind-reading wearable and citizen
robots like sofia are indicators of how
huge ai will become in the coming years
drones and robo delivery are already
being tested by companies like domino's
and doordash
despite the fact that these latest
emerging technologies are still riddled
with flaws that pose a threat to human
safety ai supplements are certain to
become a technological trend in the
future giving their immense potential
needless to say companies like nvidia
google microsoft and every other company
is adopting artificial intelligence in
some way or the other
quantum computing
quantum computing is said to be the
future of computers
but the epoch is yet to arise and the
momentum is still building
bmw daimler and volkswagen have declared
prioritizing research on quantum
computing designed to resolve
difficulties simply it still comes at a
cost
by superimposing an entanglement these
computers exploit quantum mechanical
processes to address computational
difficulties the computer employs
quantum physics to store data and
execute computations that outperform
supercomputers in solving specific tasks
since the rise of the kobit 19 pandemic
quantum computers have also been used to
create cures and potential vaccines
companies like accenture amazon hitachi
and google among others have adopted
quantum computing today
computer vision computer vision is a
branch of artificial intelligence that
allows computers and systems to extract
useful information from digital photos
videos and other visual inputs as well
as to conduct actions or make
recommendations based on that data
artificial intelligence has made
significant strides in recent years
surpassing humans in several tasks
relating to object detection and
classification
thanks to breakthroughs in artificial
intelligence and innovations in deep
learning and neural networks
computer vision is employed in a variety
of industries including energy and
utilities manufacturing and automotive
and the industry is still growing
by 2022 it is estimated to reach usd
48.6 billion
the most popular computer vision
companies include sensetime tractable
vacada and hawkeye innovations among
others
digital twin a digital twin is a virtual
representation of a physical object that
is designed to exactly reflect it
the object under investigation is
equipped with a variety of sensors
these sensors collect data on the energy
production temperature weather
conditions and other characteristics of
the physical objects performance
this information is subsequently sent to
a processing machine where it is applied
to a digital copy
this technology is being used for
buildings manufacturing plants cars or
any complex object to monitor
this will assist in the transformation
of numerous processes as well as the
detection of potential future breakdowns
events or abnormalities in their
functioning
companies like microsoft ibm siemens
cisco and oracle among the other top
tier companies use the technology of
digital twin
autonomous driving the fact that
self-driving cars are coming to life has
left everyone awestruck
although we do not routinely travel in
or see them the coming years will mark
some special pivotal times for the newer
innovations to come
although autonomous cars have stormed
the market today using data gathering
and analytics new technology trends and
functionalities like autonomous braking
lane changing and automation of other
in-car systems are on the way to being
streamlined
although there are a few shortcomings
that are yet to be resolved there's no
ruling out the fact that the streets
will see more and more of autonomous
cars in the near future
tesla audi ford apple waymo kia and
other companies are immensely working
with making driving completely
autonomous
intelligent process automation
intelligent process automation ipa is
the use of artificial intelligence and
related emerging technologies to robotic
process automation such as computer
vision cognitive automation and machine
learning
according to mckinsey organizations in
several industries that have
experimented with intelligent process
automation have achieved impressive
results with the automation of about 50
to 70 percent of tasks 25 to 30 percent
annual cost reduction and roi in triple
digit percentages
it's safe to say the main benefit of
intelligent process automation is the
significant amplifications of the
returns rpa offers companies like cat
gemini deloitte ibm sap etc are reading
deploying intelligent process automation
in their organizations
with that being said if you wish to
create something cool and help make a
difference check out simplylearn's
postgraduate program in ai and machine
learning in partnership with purdue
university and in collaboration with ibm
it covers topics like machine learning
deep learning statistics and nlp among
others
in conclusion with such big advancements
in technology the future looks more
promising than ever
it is likely to reshape all sectors of
life
there is simply no stopping it
have you heard about the new innovations
that have been recently implemented
let us know in the comment section below
thank you for being here and watch out
for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here